32 ordinateurs des écrans géants l'hôtel
de ville de versailles s'est transformé
en une salle d'arcade géante ce samedi
27 janvier
au programme une compétition du célèbre
jeu médiéval fantastique stone une
discipline pratiquée par plus de 70
millions de joueurs à travers le monde
on a offert aux différents le but c'est
de faire un dec en quarts paquet de 30
cartes ont réuni nos trois meilleurs car
on choisit le héros qu'on veut et on
confond de notre héros au héros adverses
et on va avoir un système de points de
vie la pandémie c'est notre vie et le
but ça va être de mettre les points de
vie réduite à zéro pour ce premier
rendez vous du sport tas versailles 2
compétition était organisée en parallèle
la première réunit ces huit des
meilleurs joueurs de france
tous professionnels pré sélectionnés
parmi plus de 1000 candidats
la seconde et est ouverte et des joueurs
amateurs nous on considère que dans les
jeux vidéo
les gens ont l'habitude d'être actif
devant leur écran et donc on considère
que quand ils viennent c'est juste pour
regarder les joueurs
et ben voilà il vous regardez une heure
ils vont regarder deux heures et puis
bon évidemment il va repartir
et donc ce mix des deux fait que les
joueurs jouent leur parti
regardez partie de pros jouent leur
parti et c'est souvent quelque chose qui
marche pas très bien
amateurs ou professionnels tous au jeu
cette compétition intensément comme de
véritables sportifs
certains joueurs se sont entraînés
pendant plusieurs semaines pour réaliser
des performances sur ce rendez vous il y
a une intensité qui mentale surtout mais
qui se répercute sur le physique
et derrière il faut aussi savoir
entretenir son corps enrichit ses pales
tous de jouer tout le temps sur le
bénéfice à maurice faire du sport à côté
justement pour entretenir sa forme
mentale et physique des sacrifices
récompensés comme dans toutes les
compétitions sportives le vainqueur chez
les professionnels à remporter 1000
euros et des lots ont été distribués
chez les amateurs une nouvelle édition
pourrait être programmé à versailles
prochainement